so
like have you in uh you know like
with civilian circumstances like at a
bar or whatever like you know
house party like coffee shop they
haven't had people
say oh dude would you choke me out and
and
yeah yeah it's weird i just don't
understand it you know
i don't do it i don't do it at all not
so much to choke me out more the leg
kicks
you know
weird sick bastards out there they want
to be leg kicked
you know and they're going hey can you
just i mean i've had people ask me to
chill them out as well and leg kick and
i don't do it a couple of times it did
at the start and then the ufc pulled me
to one side
and i think the ufc actually sent out a
mass email to all the fighters
from now on because it's a weird like
petty thing that guys want
from now on if anybody asks you to choke
them out or kick them in the leg
do not do it because you're at serious
risk of a lawsuit because you could you
imagine if you hurt somebody
uh so yeah no i don't do that that's so
funny i was in dana white's office
and uh i was you know out there
um you know i'm getting i asked him if i
could get a press pass and that would
sort of get me past the coved bit
you know and so i could actually go to
the fights in person and i was like yeah
dude i'll make a rad video i'll you know
promote the ufc it'll be it'll be
it'll be cool and uh so you know
he was so nice to invite me to his
office and we hung out for like a half
an hour
and uh and i was like you know what
would make this video really perform
maybe if you choked me out and i
i felt like i was so close i almost i
had like and
you know and he was like yeah you know
it's kind of looked like he was really
gonna do it now that i jumped up in the
air i'm like yeah
awesome and then i could see him kind of
think about it he said why don't we do
it in the octagon
you know at the fights tomorrow yeah
and uh i i know i know never to bug him
about that one again
uh no dave is the man though oh he is oh
my god he's my hero no he's [ __ ]
awesome he really is i got so much
respect for the guy he's my hero
yeah i mean danny could choke you out
have you seen the size of the arms on
the guy these days he's
[ __ ] working out like a maniac
richard you know what i get asked
constantly
is what will i kick them in the nuts oh
my god
no way yeah no way if somebody tries to
if someone did that for a laugh yeah
then we're gonna have
i'm gonna come out of retirement pretty
quick
yeah dude like i had like i even had
i have to turn people down constantly i
said no i'm you know
i know i've i've retired from not
kicking i just don't do it anymore
and then every so often i come out of
retirement
why not hold on let me get this right so
you're kicking them in the notes
they're begging
these impassioned pitches like dude is
there any way
i could get you to kick me in the nuts
this would be my dream
what is going on in the world i mean i
know when some funny times these days
you know what i mean because it's bad
news to be a man
you know what i mean especially a white
man but asking someone to kick you in
the [ __ ] balls
jesus christ especially in australia
like he would kick him in the nuts
they'd get back up and want it again
like three or four times he kicked the
same person
it's been going on for a long time too
but hey you know what
what are you gonna do i mean everybody
has their like niches it's like you get
asked to get leg kicked stone cold wants
to get arm wrestled
you get yeah do people try to fight you
michael like because i
like ufc fighters people for some reason
they see him they're like yeah like any
fighter
yeah yeah for the most part for the most
part people are cool
you know what i mean certainly you know
i've certainly had once or twice
over the years i've had a couple of
[ __ ] i was in this place once in
manchester and like some gang lads
came in and yeah i knew there was going
to be an issue there because they don't
fight with the fists you know what i
mean it was all knives and guns i was
like oh [ __ ] here we go
uh but uh generally people are okay i'm
tough guys
you know tough guys are dormant security
they know they watch and they always
have respect
so as i say generally for the most part
people just come up and say hey what's
up man respect you know whatever
handshake quick picture whatever yeah
and and
i don't really put myself in those
situations to be honest anyway so
uh i'm pretty good i mean when i was a
kid yeah i was a bit of a [ __ ] i was
always
always getting in trouble but yeah i i
learned my lesson the hard way
thank you so much for watching this clip
and guess what
i have the number 30 ranked hot sauce on
all of
amazon it's called stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon and buy stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole
yeah yeah
dude